salut aujourd'hui je vous emmène en 1920
dans une histoire digne d'un multivers
de Marvel puisque je vous parlais d'une
opposition qui a eu lieu entre le père
de Sherlock Holmes Conan Doyle et le
plus grand magicien de son époque Houdin
sœur Arthur Conan Doyle c'est l'un des
auteurs les plus lus dans le monde c'est
le père de Sherlock Holmes quant à
Houdini de son vrai nom Éric West c'est
le plus grand magicien de son époque
d'ailleurs il s'est fait appeler Houdini
en référence au père fondateur de la
magie moderne j'engen Robert Houda sa
spécialité c'est l'évasion on l'appelle
d'ailleurs Houdini ou simplement le
Maître de l'évasion depuis que la police
de Chicago l'a mis au défi de sortir en
moins de 30 minutes d'une cellule de
prison il a réussi d'ailleurs ce défi
peint 30 minutes mais en trois heures et
ensuite il a essayé des tentatives
d'évasion toujours plus risquées pour
lui il s'est fait enfermé dans un énorme
polaire rempli d'eau il s'est fait
enterré vivant et devait s'en sortir
évidemment il s'est fait suspendre par
les pieds depuis le haut d'un immeuble
bref il défile la mort à chaque fois ça
fait déjà deux décennies que ces deux
personnes jouissent d'une immense
célébrité dans le monde entier mais il
ne se connaissent pas encore pourtant le
secret qui va les lier va aussi
peut-être les détruire c'est la chose
qui va fonder leur amitié qui va être le
ciment de cette amitié pendant plusieurs
années mais c'est la même raison qui va
les faire se séparer mais avant
d'aborder le sujet de dîner qui comme je
vous le disais et l'un des plus grands
magiciens de son époque on va parler de
l'un des plus grands magiciens de notre
époque c'est Luc Langevin alors
attention on dirait qu'il y a un gros
parti pris parce que je suis en train de
vous faire un placement de copains je
sais pas si ça se dit mais je vais
donner un peu de données factuelle même
si dans le fond vous le connaissez
sûrement parce qu'il y a déjà un demi
million de spectateurs qui ont vu ces
spectacles et vous l'avez déjà vu sur ma
chaîne youtube on avait fait une
interview à la table ensemble puis on a
fait plein de vidéos sur ma chaîne
depuis 2018 alors pourquoi je vous
raconte tout ça aujourd'hui et pourquoi
je vous dis que c'est un placement de
copains parce que je voulais vous
annoncer que Luc Langevin revenait en
France pour présenter son nouveau
spectacle qui s'appelle vérité au Casino
de Paris ça commence le 28 septembre et
ça s'arrêtera le premier octobre et il a
en ouverture
un invité un peu particulier c'est moi
je vais faire une sorte de première
partie sur les cinq représentations
qu'il fait de vérités au Casino de Paris
parce que avec lui qu'on discutant on
s'est aperçut que on se connaît depuis
longtemps on s'aime bien humainement
mais on aime bien aussi chacun le
travail de l'autre et on s'est rendu
compte qu'on a jamais partagé la même
scène et ben ce sera fait je suis très
content qu'on puisse faire ça et
j'espère que vous serez nombreux et
nombreuses à devenir nous voir là-bas je
vous mettrai un lien dans la description
je vais essayer de vous raconter vite
fait le spectacle sans trop vous spoil
c'est le spectacle le plus spectaculaire
que Luc et jamais écrit et fait c'est un
spectacle qui mêle beaucoup de choses la
Grande Illusion moderne la magie bien
sûr l'humour le mentalisme aussi la
poésie et sans m'avancer je peux te dire
que c'est un spectacle qui va vraiment
vous marquer voilà vous voyez bien que
je fais référence à quelque chose que je
peux pas vous dire mais ça va vraiment
vous marquer et si ce que j'aime bien
dans vérité c'est qu'on dit souvent
qu'il faut le voir pour le croire sauf
que là dans le spectacle vous allez
vraiment réaliser que c'est pas parce on
voit quelque chose qu'il faut le croire
et que ça existe et c'est pas parce
qu'il y a quelque chose qu'on ne voit
pas qu'il n'existe pas je vous résume il
vient du Québec pour seulement 5
représentations du 28 septembre au
premier octobre au Casino de Paris et
après il y aura une tournée en France
c'est un spectacle qui marche pour
toutes les générations donc n'hésitez
pas à venir voir le clan juin et moi si
vous venez au Casino de Paris sur scène
je vous mets de toute manière tous les
liens qui font en description si vous
voulez prendre votre place en 1913
Houdini perd sa mère brutalement il est
dévasté évidemment et il va aller à la
rencontre de beaucoup de médiums pour
essayer de communiquer avec elle alors
ça vous paraît peut-être étrange mais en
1913 le spiritisme est à la mode et
c'est quelque chose qui pour beaucoup
semble réel c'est pour ça qu'il va
commencer à essayer de rentrer en
contact avec elle le problème c'est
qu'il va reconnaître très rapidement les
techniques un peu bon marché qu'il
connaît parce que lui-même les utilisent
en tant qu'illusionniste en plus ils
font pas forcément attention à la
crédibilité de ce qu'ils font c'est pas
des grandes techniques très élaboré
comme chez les illusionnistes puisque de
toute manière ils ne prétendent pas
donner l'illusion d'eux et il parle à
des gens qui sont convaincus et ça ça le
révolte pour lui c'est simplement du
charlatanisme utilisé des techniques
dans un spectacle d'illusion c'est ok
les utiliser en faisant croire que c'est
réel pour communiquer avec les morts là
vraiment au dîné ça le fait pas et c'est
pour cette raison que la carrière
d'oudini va prendre un autre tournant il
décide quasiment du jour au lendemain de
faire une croisade contre ces
personnes-là qui prétendent pouvoir
communiquer avec l'au-delà mais qu'il
utilise en réalité de simples trucages
au dîner commence à enquêter sur les
médiums en assistant un maximum de
séances le but pour lui de prendre des
notes de démontrer ses supercheries et
de les publier il présentera le résultat
de ses enquêtes dans plusieurs ouvrages
que vous voyez apparaître ici et il
semble pas impertinent de dire que ce
que vous voulez utiliser le plus profond
de son désir c'était pas de débusquer un
charlatan c'était de trouver une
personne qui avait vraiment les pouvoirs
qu'elle prétendait avoir pour
communiquer avec sa mère et à partir de
ce moment là que Conan Doyle va
apparaître dans la vie d'oudini Doyle il
fait partie des grands défenseurs du
spiritisme et des médiums il y croit
fermement il a écrit beaucoup de livres
sur le sujet il donne même des
conférences sur le sujet et sa deuxième
femme l'exigeant est elle-même médium
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs pour ça que
Conan Doyle déteste son héros qu'il l'a
fait connaître Sherlock Holmes parce que
Charles comme c'est très cartésien il
l'a toujours eu en horreur et c'est même
pour ça qui va le tuer en 1893 dans une
nouvelle puis il aurait suscité en 1901
contre une forte somme d'argent que lui
propose son éditeur et l'intérêt kakonan
Doyle pour le spiritisme et l'au-delà
trouve ses racines dans les mêmes
raisons que celles qui ont poussé Audi
ni à s'y intéresser je prends mes notes
pour écorcher aucun nom ou aucune date
mais malheureusement dold a perdu
beaucoup de personnes sa première épouse
louisa est morte d'une tuberculose son
fils Kingsley et décédé d'une pneumonie
en 1918 soit 2 ans avant l'histoire
qu'on va raconter là son frère cadet est
mort également de pneumonie en 1919 mais
aussi c'est de beau-frères c'est de
neveux durant la première guerre etc etc
ce qu'il a fait tomber d'ailleurs dans
une lourde dépression et cette
dépression il va s'en sortir grâce au
spiritisme qui va l'aider à remonter la
pente tout en prenant contact avec les
défunts alors d'un côté on a Houdini qui
a décelé directement les supercheries et
qui est très déçu de ne pas pouvoir
rentrer en contact avec sa mère et de
l'autre côté on a Conan Doyle qui est
convaincu qu'il est entré en contact
avec son fils et qui pourrait tout
donner pour prouver au monde entier que
le spiritisme ça existe bel et bien
c'est quasi scientifique pour lui en
1920 après avoir lu miracle mongerse un
verre méthode Conan Doyle envoie une
lettre à audini il le félicite pour ses
travaux pour son enquête il lui dit au
contraire que c'est très bien de
dépister tous ces faux médium tous ces
charlatans pour qu'on puisse reconnaître
enfin ceux qui ont un véritable don un
véritable pouvoir alors ça fait sourire
au dîner de se dire que quelqu'un comme
croient au surnaturel néanmoins il reste
flatté qu'un homme de sa trempe et de
d'une telle notoriété s'intéresse à son
travail ils vont s'écrire comme ça un
certain temps quelques échanges
épistolaires jusqu'à temps que Doyle a
vite ou dîner à dîner à Londres lors de
cette première rencontre le Guinée se
passe très bien et les deux sortants à
merveilles c'est-à-dire que dans un sens
deuil prend beaucoup la parole et aimait
beaucoup de cœur à expliquer par contre
à Ottignies que le speritisme existe bel
et bien que l'au-delà existe bel et bien
de son côté lui ou dîner ne se voit pas
clamer trop ou trop fort vis-à-vis des
Dolls et de ses invités que dans 100%
des cas selon lui c'est du charlatanisme
donc il va protester et il va surtout
passer son temps à faire quelques
numéros d'illusionnistes pour montrer
qu'on peut facilement duper quelqu'un et
là on entre dans une autre dimension
Doyle adore les numéros que fait ou Dimi
il est très très impressionné tellement
impressionné qu'il est persuadé
qu'en réalité il n'y a pas de trucs au
dîner à un don particulier donc là où
Dini change de position exprime sans
aucun doute que ce qui fait ce sont le
simple tour de passe-passe qu'il y a un
trucage et que il a aucun pouvoir sauf
que Doyle ne va pas le croire il se dit
soit il a des pouvoirs surnaturels et il
le cache soit il croit ne pas avoir de
pouvoir surnaturel mais c'est quand même
grâce à ses pouvoirs qu'il arrive à
faire ce qu'il a à faire il s'en rende
même pas compte et dans tous les cas
Conan doy un argument qui lui semble
imparable il se dit ce n'est pas parce
que vous arrivez à reproduire des
phénomènes à volonté avec du matériel et
une méthode que certains n'arrivent pas
à le reproduire d'une manière
surnaturelle d'ailleurs par la suite
Conan dog va déclarer à la presque si
Houdini arrive à être le roi de
l'évasion c'est simplement parce qu'il
arrive à dématérialiser son corps d'un
endroit pour le rematérialiser ailleurs
en 1922 Doyle invite Houdini et sa femme
baisse allée rejoindre pour passer
quelques vacances lors de ce séjour la
femme de Conan Doyle les 10 gens
proposent à Houdini de faire une séance
de médium et de spiritisme pour rentrer
en contact avec sa mère défunte alors il
faut pas oublier que depuis le départ
dans le fond ou dîner sa première
démarche c'était de vouloir rentrer en
contact avec sa mère il veut y croire à
la base il attend juste une preuve
probante et pour l'instant
l'accumulation des démonstrations de
charlatanisme et d'escroquerie lui font
perdre le goût mais il reste toujours
une étincelle en lui donc il accepte il
s'installe à table et il dit qu'il a
l'esprit ouvert qu'il est prêt à
accueillir tous les messages qui pourra
recevoir et qu'il est ici sans aucun
jugement préalable la séance démarre est
très vite Jane Doyle rentre en transe sa
grande spécialité c'est l'écriture
automatique il y a l'écrit à l'écrit à
l'écrit des mots qui proviennent de
Cecilia la mère d'oudini un message
relativement banal j'en ai une copie que
je vais vous lire je suis heureuse de
parler je suis fier de toi je suis au
paradis et c'est un milieu sublime je
vais bien Houdini va alors demander à sa
mère si elle peut lire dans ses pensées
ce que les dit Jane affirme alors elle
écrit et au total elle écrira 5 pages
complètes mais au final on dit est très
déçu il est plus que déçu il est en
colère ce jour-là précisément c'était le
jour de l'anniversaire de la mère de
Jimmy et elle n'en a pas fait référence
elle n'en a pas fait mention tous les
mots écrits sont dans un anglais
impeccable alors que la mère d'oudini ne
parlait que hongrois et yiddish chacune
des pages est signée par une petite
croix catholique alors que la mère de
Dini était juive quant à la lecture de
pensée ou d'ini penser à son ami Powell
et évidemment la mère de lignes ne l'a
pas trouvé alors Houdini ne veut pas
gâcher la fin des vacances il ne veut
pas d'ailleurs mettre un coup de canif
dans l'amitié qu'il a avec les deuils il
est quasiment certain d'une chose c'est
que les deuils n'ont pas voulu le duper
n'ont pas monté une supercherie
consciente donc au fond de lui il pense
qu'ils se sont un peu empêtrés dans leur
propre croyance et qui sont eux-mêmes
persuadés qu'elle arrive à communiquer
avec les défunts il ne dit rien de
spécifique ni en bien mis en mal et les
vacances se poursuivent mais Houdini peu
de temps après dans la presse va
déclarer qu'il n'a toujours pas eu de
démonstration et de preuve probante sur
le fait que le spiritisme existe et
qu'on peut avoir contact avec les
défunts et cette annonce publique va
profondément vexer les Dogs en 1922 le
magazine scientifique américain propose
un prix de 2500 dollars à quiconque
serait capable de démontrer l'existence
d'un effet surnaturel parmi les médiums
qui vont aussi présenter il y en a une
particulièrement qui affectionne Conan
Doyle dont ils vend tous les mérites il
s'agit de Mina crenden une médium très
réputée à Boston et deuil est persuadé
que Mina appelait aussi Marjorie va
démontrer d'une manière
réfutable à hodini que les médiums
existent bel et bien les arguments
jouant la faveur de deuil parce que Mina
crandon allait marier à un brillant
chirurgien de Boston elle ne fait jamais
payer ses séances de médium et ses
consultations et d'ailleurs à déjà
exprimée publiquement qu'elle ne
voudrait pas du prix de 2500 dollars
qu'on pourra en faire ce qu'on veut donc
puisque elle ne fait jamais payer
qu'elle n'est jamais intéressée par
l'argent c'est pour le grand public une
preuve que c'est bel et bien de médium
oudini fait partie du comité qui
reçoivent les médiums pour voir leur
démonstration et attester si vraiment
raisonnablement il y a eu quelque chose
de surnaturel ou pas des auteurs ou pas
mais évidemment il va pas rencontrer
chacun des médiums le comité fait pas
toujours appel à lui il est composé
d'autres personnes des psychologues des
scientifiques etc jusqu'au jour où il
apprend dans le Journal qu'on va
décerner le Prix Amina crandon alors
qu'il ne l'a jamais rencontré et en
réalité ils ne l'ont pas convié à la
rencontrer parce qu'ils ont déjà réalisé
plus de 80 séances lesquels et que
toutes ont été concluantes le 23 juillet
1924 ou Dini se rend précipitamment à
Boston et exige d'assister à une séance
Marjorie accepte reçoit tout le comité
il s'installe chez elle dans son grand
salon la pénombre est mise et elle
commence à rentrer en contact avec son
frère défunt parce qu'elle affirme que
c'est d'abord en rentrant en contact
avec son propre frère à elle défunt
qu'elle rentre en contact avec le reste
des défunts et des phénomènes se
produisent la table de spiritisme se met
à bouger une clochette isolée se met à
teinter évidemment on ne voit rien parce
qu'on est dans le noir mais de toute
manière tout le monde touche la main de
tout le monde vous savez comment ça se
passe on se met autour d'une table et on
connecte les mains ensemble ce qui est
une preuve viréutable que personne ne
peut toucher au centre de la table ou de
la faire bouger à la sortie de la séance
Houdini est impressionné c'est bien la
première fois d'ailleurs qu'il est
autant impressionné par quelqu'un
impressionné mais pas dupe pour lui la
supercherie est très claire pourtant
pour les autres personnes du comité il
reste persuadés Canada de réel pouvoir
alors au Dini va créer une boîte pas
n'importe quel boîte une boîte pour la
médium qui va s'appeler la largeurie box
le but est que pendant la séance
Marjorie soit dans la boîte dont
seulement la tête dépasse ce qui
l'empêcherait de bouger de manière
subtile la clochette ou d'interférer
avec des mouvements potentiels de la
table à l'aide de ses pieds il va y
avoir plusieurs séances bien sûr
plusieurs tests dans aucune des séances
ou marjories est enfermée dans la
Majorie box il ne se passe quelque chose
dès qu'elle est plus libre complètement
de ces mouvements la clochette ne sonne
plus la table ne bouge plus d'ailleurs
Houdini avait anticipé les papiers et
point liés c'est vraiment une boîte où
elle a de l'espace pour bouger parce
qu'elle avait dit que si on l'a lié elle
pouvait pas rentrer en contact donc il a
respecté ses demandes et cette boîte est
vraiment très large vous en avez
sûrement là une photo à vient de tuer la
réputation d'une des plus célèbres
médium et ça Doyle le prend très mal et
le programme n'affront et d'ailleurs
Ubaldi un public un pour lui Houdini à
sa beauté sciemment les séances et les
tests de Mina cette fois entre deuil et
Houdini l'amitié définitivement rompue
et pour l'anecdote cette boîte va
devenir tellement célèbre qu'elle va
intégrer le spectacle d'oudinisme
spectacle dénonçait les charlatans de là
Houdini et Dole n'ont plus aucun contact
presque un contact télépathique parce
qu'ils se suivent l'un l'autre quand
Houdini va faire la tournée de son
spectacle qui dénonce les charlatans
Doyle en même temps va faire la même
tournée c'est à dire les mêmes villes
après coup Dini soit passée pour donner
des conférences sur le sujet du
spiritisme et de la médiumnité pour
ramener un peu les gens dans la bonne
croyance selon lui et plus le tournée du
spectacle d'oudini avance plus il se
crée un ennemi la communauté des spirits
la communauté des médiums il devient
leur ennemi juré numéro un d'ailleurs il
va même proposer une loi pour interdire
cette pratique la loi ne sera pas
adoptée comme vous le savez sûrement
déjà mais en parallèle il va écrire un
livre pour les policiers où il va leur
expliquer toutes les techniques que les
pickpockets utilisent il les connaît lui
en tant que magicien et homme de scène
les techniques de cold reading de
lecture à froid pour mieux identifier ce
qui se passe pour mieux détecter un
charlatan etc alors certaines personnes
pensent que la mort nous dit ni aurait
été prémédité ou commandité c'est une
allégation rien n'est là pour étayer ça
et si on n'a pas de preuve que ça avait
été prémédité je peux néanmoins vous
raconter les faits le 22 octobre 1926 ou
d'ini se trouve en spectacle au Théâtre
princesse à Montréal seateur Princess et
à cette époque il disait qu'il était
invincible en spectacle il invitait
régulièrement des personnes de fortes
Constitution à lui donner un coup de
poing dans le ventre coup de poing qui
l'encaissait à chaque fois ce soir là
Houdini est assis dans l'un des canapés
de sa loge et reçoit des étudiants de
l'Université McGill l'un des étudiants
Josselin Gordon Whitehead demande si
vraiment il est invin et s'il peut lui
donner un coup de poing pour le tester
ou d'iny accepte mais l'étudiant va
enchaîner directement ou dîner n'a pas
eu le temps de se préparer il est
toujours assis dans son canapé il vient
à peine de dire oui que l'étudiant va
lui mettre 4 à 5 coups de poing énorme
extrêmement bien placé et au Dily
n'était pas du tout prêt à ça il va
ressentir une énorme douleur
considérable les joueurs qui vont suivre
ou d'ini va avoir de violentes fièvre et
des douleurs atroces à son ventre mais
il veut continuer la tournée du
spectacle coûte que coûte il va la
continuer sans voir de médecin il veut
même pas en parler et alors qu'il est
sur scène en train de se produire à des
trois il va s'écrouler sur scène
s'effondrer littéralement être emmené à
l'hôpital ils vont essayer de lui
retirer l'appendicite mais rien n'y fait
l'infection était déjà trop avancée et
au dîner va décéder d'une péritonite
aiguë le 31 octobre 1926 il y a deux
hypothèses sur les circonstances de sa
mort aucune des deux n'est vraiment
confirmée et il s'agit probablement d'un
mix des deux la première c'est que
Houdini souffrait déjà de de vendre
avant ça rencontre avec white aide son
appendice était sûrement déjà infecté et
une péritonite aurait été quoi qu'il
arrive inévitable la deuxième c'est que
les coups de poing de White aide
auraient rompu l'appendice de hodini et
provoquer la péritonite aiguë ce qu'il
faut retenir ces coups dignes n'étaient
pas complètement fermée avec l'idée
qu'on puisse communiquer avec l'au-delà
simplement il n'est jamais parvenu à
trouver des preuves irréfutables qui lui
permettait de confirmer leur existence
d'ailleurs avant de mourir il a composé
un code de 10 mots avec sa femme
vraiment que au dîner et sa femme qu'il
connaissait et ils avaient dit si l'un
de nous deux vient à mourir alors
l'autre viendra lui transmettre ce code
depuis de l'au-delà si l'au-delà
évidemment existe et si on est capable
de communiquer avec les personnes
disparues évidemment sa femme n'a jamais
reçu le code Houdini qui avait trompé la
mort tant de fois dans sa vie ne l'avait
pas vu arriver le genre de ces fameux
coup de poing mais ça me tenait à cœur
depuis longtemps de vous partager
l'histoire du moins une partie de son
histoire et surtout ce qui m'a toujours
fasciné de me dire qu'il a vécu en même
temps que Conan dog le père de Sherlock
Holmes qu'ils se sont croisés et qu'ils
ont eu des interactions une amitié et
puis ensuite tu ne séparation vis-à-vis
du sujet qu'on a vu là dans la vidéo je
trouve ça un petit peu fascinant de
regarder à l'extérieur depuis notre
époque alors qu'on a une imagerie de
Dini une imagerie de Sherlock Holmes et
de Conan Doyle et de de revoir tout ça
mélanger je trouvais ça un petit peu un
petit peu incroyable comme je trouverais
ça incroyable de vous voir du coup au
spectacle de Luc Langevin au Casino de
Paris sinon moi je serai pas de se faire
sa tournée j'ai ma propre tournée avec
mon propre spectacle mais s'il passe
près de chez vous n'hésitez pas vraiment
à aller le voir je vous le rappelle je
vous mets tout dans la description à
très bientôt Ciao